So this sample may not look very much
but it's a sample of the saltiest water that you can find on this planet.
It comes from a really small lake - not even a lake, a pond - in the north of Ethiopia.
This was collected by one of my friends,
Eduardo Perez, when he was on holiday
collected in a plastic water bottle and then he analyzed it and found that it was the saltiest water
that's ever been discovered, and he's got it into the Guinness World Records.
Ethiopia, in case you've forgotten, is on the
eastern part of Africa, quite close to the equator, and right in the north there's a region called the Danakil Depression
which is well below sea level. It's part of the rift valley
which is an area of huge seismic and volcanic activity.
And in 2005, following an earthquake, a new lake appeared.
I'm sure I don't pronounce it correctly, but its name looks to me as if it's pronounced Gaet'ale.
What is really unusual is the water is very hot.
60 degrees centigrade - that's hotter than you can bear to jump into. And it's hot because
there is a hot spring coming through the volcanic rock, and not only is it coming up and bubbling up
into the lake (you can see great bubbles coming up), but at the same time it is dissolving
salts that are in the soil. The concentration of the salt is so high,
a mixture of calcium and magnesium chloride, that the water is actually
saturated. You cannot physically dissolve any more salt.
There is 43.3%
dissolved solids by weight. What that means is if you have a liter of water,
you have four hundred and thirty-three grams of dissolved solid...
nearly half the weight of the water.
Even in this small sample that I've got, you can see a big difference in weight.
I've got an empty bottle, a bottle of water and a bottle of the water from the pond. We weigh the empty bottle, and
this balance has a thing that is called tare
which allows us to set it to zero when the bottle's on there, so we'll just weigh whatever's in the bottle.
We put on...
the water...
comes to 15.5. We put this on here...
22.2.
The other thing that you might notice is that because this water is at room temperature, and this room in
Nottingham is barely 20 degrees today,
that some of the salt has precipitated.
You can see that there are crystals at the bottom, and this is because, in general, these types of salts
dissolve better in hot water than they do in cold water.
So when you put the water in here,
let it cool down, some of the things precipitate. Some of you who know chemistry will say,
"Calcium chloride and magnesium chloride are colorless,
so why is this water yellow?" and the answer is that it contains a trace of
iron(III) which forms quite a strong yellow color in the presence of high
concentrations of chloride. So although it looks yellow, the yellow component is a really tiny part.
Of course people have been looking for the saltiest water in the world for some time.
This is a new record,
and you might wonder what was the previous record... And the previous record was a pond
called the Don Juan Pond in the Antarctica
where there was a very - or there still is - a very salty lake which has
403 grams per liter of dissolved salt.
Now, the reason why it's not as salty as this pond in Ethiopia is because
Ethiopia is near the equator, and the water is hotter than in Antarctica. As you cool down water,
even though it's still saturated, it contains less salt, and the colder you go the less and less salt will dissolve.
Eventually, when it freezes to ice,
you get no salt in it at all. You might ask, "How does this compare with the Dead Sea?"
I think there's about twice as much salt or dissolved material as the Dead Sea.
According to Brady, the Dead Sea water
tastes like acid.
("I would, but we haven't got much time.")
Ugh! [spits]
("Don't... yeah, don't... you didn't just taste it.")
Yeah, it's salty! [laughs]
We're not going to taste this, but broadly it will taste twice as awful
unless its taste is logarithmic in which case it might be a lot more.
Compared to sea water it is about 14 times as salty.
Well, 14 times as much dissolved salt.
Sea water also has a different composisition: it has a lot of sodium chloride in it,
whereas there's very little sodium in this, and the reason is that this is not
a pond where sea water has evaporated,
but it's come from dissolved salts underground which do not originate from the sea.
This is Eduardo's paper,
published in the journal called Aquatic Geochemistry...
("Have you ever published in that one?")
No, because I'm not a geochemist, and I don't study water.
("Is Eduardo?")
Eduardo is not, but he is a good chemist, and good chemists can do anything!
The chemical analysis of the water of the Gaet'ale Pond,
a small water body located in the Danakil Depression, Ethipoia,
resulted to be the most saline water body on Earth with total dissolved solids of 433 grams per kilogram.
And when they...
started making these aerosols, in the aerosols they put a molecule rather like this,
which has carbon in the middle,
three fluorine atoms, and a chlorine atom.
This is the Akaki River. It's about 20 kilometers from the city centre, and we're right in the middle of...